search crews will work through the
holiday weekend to find and identify
more victims of the deadly campfire in
Northern California
the search could take months the fire
killed 84 people another 563 are still
missing the fire is almost fully
contained so firefighters spent
Thanksgiving serving the community in a
different way Carter Evans is in
Paradise with a show of goodwill Carter
good morning good morning more than
1,600 personnel are still working this
fire or what was this fire they're
shifting their focus right now to deal
with the rain they've been cutting down
trees trying to make it safe for people
to return for those who used to live
here the holiday provided a glimmer of
hope
after weeks of desperation in a place
forever changed by the devastating
Northern California wildfire
Thanksgiving was a day of reflection and
community everything
evacuees Suzette Van Horn is one of them
more than 13,000 homeowners who don't
have a house to return to this holiday
season coming here and seeing first
responders serving it just brought me to
tears because they've already done so
much she was thankful for the dozens of
firefighters who before eating their own
dinner stepped up to serve others it's
almost like this is I'd rather be here
you know it's helping other people and
that's part of what Thanksgiving is
about firefighters also got a special
thank-you from celebrity chef Jose
Andres several chefs including Guy Fieri
worked with Andres organization world
central kitchen to cook and serve 15
thousand turkey dinners and a day like
today Thanksgiving is it's precisely to
give thanks for what we receive but
especially to what everybody can give
and if you give me a bit of yourself
everything can be so much with the
hardships for homeowners won't end
anytime soon
on Thursday the county released a new
map with 360-degree images of thousands
of properties in the fire zone it'll
help owners who are still evacuated
assess the devastation most are trying
to focus on what's truly
well I am thankful for having for my
life and for having my dog on my cat
with me I have no problem being thankful
for that absolutely grateful well there
still is concern about all this rain and
the forecast is here to stay at least
for this afternoon we are focused on a
flash flood watch that lasts until this
afternoon the rain is expected to go
through Saturday and then give people a
much needed break Dana
Carter Evans thank you very much I mean
the true meaning of the holiday yeah and
you know I worry sometimes that even our
first responders don't get that same
kind of love you know their families
were at risk during the fires as well
and they're out there serving those
Thanksgiving meals and reminding us of
our shared humanity that's the story of
Thanksgiving exactly